all right welcome back to drew's news
last thing a pic from the little yellow
book which is my personal curation of
all the things that i love
i want you to know about we also
collectively work on this uh with the
show and today it is blake lively's
brand new line of non-alcoholic mixers
betty buzz
i love that picture of her can we show
that again i mean this is a campaign
picture i'm like yeah i want in on that
moment
she's so beautiful inside and out and
her husband ryan ironically has a gin
out there in the world but apparently
blake is not a drinker and she sent this
to me and it's a note from her i got a
note from blake lively i was like oh my
god
um and it says please uh drink
responsibly you may actually want to
keep this for yourself chill or enjoy
with ice and mint now these are meant to
either mix with alcohol because most
people want to imbibe sometimes not
others and so she made something that
works for everybody speaking of betty
buzz this is getting all the buzz
everywhere people are really talking
about this it's delicious
oh my god i admire lemon what do you
have oh my god sparkling grapefruit yum
ugh i know what i'm drinking at my next
soiree
thanks blake
blake
you're so awesome thank you so much for
sending this to me um
zero calories oh
zero zero calories
oh my god it's so delicious you guys run
out betty buzz grab it cheers rossie
[Music]